[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editors of the delhi mirror and the sun
pepper clearer and harry cole both with
us from now until just before midnight
welcome to both of you so to the front
pages then let's start with the metro uh
quotes from a blog by the former prime
ministerial advisor dominic cummings who
insists he and other downing street
staff would be prepared to swear under
oath that boris johnson lied to
parliament about parties held at number
10 during lockdown
same story the guardian with the
headline cummings accuses pm of lying
over number 10 parties
it's also the big story for the times
the headline comings pm lied to
parliament about the party
and for the mirror as well a story from
pepper pm gave the go ahead for the
party
the eye reports that a number of
conservatives are anxious at the
prospect of mr johnson remaining in
office
the express also focusing on the prime
minister but demands his attention on
rising energy bills
the financial times understands the
government is exploring the possibility
of giving payments to energy firms
whenever wholesale gas prices increase
significantly in an attempt to cushion
the impact on customers british troops
have arrived in ukraine in a bid to stop
a feared invasion from russia that's
according to the mail
telegraph has word of sentencing reforms
proposed by the government and aimed at
clearing backlogs in courts
well the son needs with a story about
prince andrew and his soft toys based on
the testimony of a former royal police
officer
and the star has a story concerning the
actor brian blessed
we're just reminded that by scanning the
qr code that you can see on your screen
well you will be in a minute you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us there we
go there it is so click on that and
you'll be able to see what we're talking
about so let's uh join now peppa carrera
and harry cole welcome to both of you um
yet another day of headlines that uh
downey street will be
tuning out from no doubt pippa let's
start with your paper
pm gave the go ahead for the party why
is this so important and significant
well mps came back to westminster today
after speaking to constituents over the
weekend
and
and also party activists and uh compared
we're comparing notes all day as to how
bad the sort of party gate row had gone
down in this constituencies there was a
feeling last week there was a huge
amount of anger and number ten was
hoping that without any more revelations
over the weekend they'd be able to get
back on the front foot and push ahead
with this operation red meat of uh
populist announcements things like the
bbc license fee and uh we'll be talking
about later channel migrants and
bringing in the military to help uh stop
so many people crossing but uh that
looked like it might be the case for a
few hours and then dominic cummings
wants obviously boris johnson's closest
advisor and now probably his biggest foe
dropped one another of his of his
grenades um when it comes to the the
party gate the partygate round uh you
will remember this time last week or
sorry not even this time last week five
days ago prime minister's question time
boris johnson apologized after an email
leaked about
sent from his senior civil servant in
his office about bring your own booze
party in the number 10 garden and he
didn't deny that he had been at it he
just claimed that he implicitly believed
his choice of words that it was a work
event rather than a social one despite
the fact that sources were saying that
there was a table with lots of booze on
it his wife was there drinking alcohol
and some suggestion that that he'd been
warned about the event in advance in
advance number 10 categorically denied
um at the weekend
claims by dominic lawson the columnist
and the telegraph that um i'm sorry
sunday times i think he was writing in
um that uh two sources had in fact told
the prime minister
uh in advance that it was a party that
wasn't a good idea and they denied that
again this morning at the lobby that
harry and i were at the number 10 lobby
and then this afternoon dominic cummings
put out another of his infamous now
infamous blogs in which he claimed that
two senior officials had indeed
suggested to martin reynolds the senior
civil servant that he should tell the
prime minister um that it wasn't a good
idea that reynolds had said he'd go and
check and that the prime minister had
allegedly said to go ahead with it
cummings also claims that he himself won
the prime minister it wasn't a good idea
but got the brush off and that boris
johnson was keen to go to the garden
regardless
the brush off just to quote the brush
off martin's invited the building to a
drinks party this is what i'm talking
about you've got to grip this mad house
so so where does that leave boris then
um harry uh you know
being told he's got to grip this
madhouse and not doing it by the look of
it
well this is becoming a bit of a death
match now it's now
um he said versus he said i suppose with
as pippa says the uh the aid turned
rogue uh turned nemesis
now the forcefulness of the denials from
number 10 both on the record off the
record
at lobby from the prime minister
spokesman he's a civil service appointee
he you know he will be toast if there is
evidence to that can back up dumb
cummings versions of events now there
was a fear that um
that dom cummings would wait until sue
gray had eventually will it be late this
week or early next week come back with
her report into all of these uh all of
these parties all these gatherings these
drinks going on and then he would drop a
load more allegations it seems that the
cummings has decided to wait i decided
to not to wait for that i went for it at
five o'clock as um as pippa said uh just
a moment ago there was a feeling today
that lots of ministers came back i've
been sort of in the comments as early
this morning speaking to lots of people
the tea room chats the the feeling that
actually things weren't quite as bad as
they thought they were going to be when
mps got back to their constituencies
over the weekend it was a feeling
actually let's get on with this week see
how it goes you know as as long as
there's no more revelations uh the prime
minister's in a slightly stronger
position i think than he was um before
the weekend now what this comes down to
though is
it is one person's word against another
at the moment i think if dom cummings
had some sort of whatsapp message or
email proof that the prime minister's
been told then i think it the problems
would be a very serious position now
almost you know talks of game over if
he's been proven to lie but it is going
to be come down to his word versus
cummings and cummings is a man who has
admitted
that he wasn't entirely truthful
about the his own lockdown breaking um
with his infamous trip to barnard castle
in his eyesight and i think
lots of mps do not like dominic cummings
he is not
seen as a sort of uh a neutral witness
so to speak or indeed a particularly
reliable witness but it's clear he's not
going to be going uh quietly and um he's
got his eyes fixed on bringing down the
prime minister and he's going to keep
keep saying it and keep punching that
bruise until he gets his way yes the
metro to uh you know elsewhere on oath
at the pm lied to the house um you know
we would never ask your sources uh pippa
for the range of stories that the mirror
has brought to the table on this one but
presumably dominic cummings as you said
will not stop whether other people will
join in too after the sugray report uh
you know to test see what was said to
her uh is is also possible um but some
people suggesting uh in reaction to this
um you know the pm
having to leave his job because he drank
wine in his own garden you know with or
without work colleagues because the may
the 15th photograph we've got is him sat
having wine and cheese uh with his i
think she was then fiance wasn't she and
their their new baby with work
colleagues had just come out of a news
conference
so
you know
would that be some of the more bizarre
ways of losing a prime minister
well i think well go back to your first
point obviously i would never talk about
my sources but one thing i'm always
quite intrigued by is the amount of
people that say that this is a massive
campaign orchestrated by dominic
cummings clearly he's played a huge role
but if anyone thinks that dominic
cummings would talk to me after the
barnard castle story then i think
they've got another thing coming um i
think i've met the man once at tory
conference some time ago
pandemic and and that's it um but uh yes
of course i mean actually one of the
sort of the throwy lines at the end of
dominic's blog this evening was um that
there were
he he was he believed that there were
photos of other events later some of the
events that we we reported on and
developed christmas 2020 and so on um
that that was still to come out and that
sort of leads me to wonder whether he in
fact has those he left number 10 at that
point but whether he had sold people
inside or or you know contacts
who have furnished him with those
pictures and that he's planning on on
getting them out there at some point i
mean clearly that's the sort of thing
that number 10 will be very worried
about um
i don't think that the the party that
you mentioned not the party the
gathering you mentioned which number
tennis insisted was work dominic
cummings himself has said that it was
work sitting around in the garden garden
uh with wine and cheese and that was
obviously the picture on the front of
the guardian um i don't think that will
be the one to bring him down if any of
these indeed do bring him down um but uh
you know the accumulative effect
yes there will have to be some sort of
smoking gun about one particular
incident in the may 20th 2021 at the
moment looks the most likely but don't
forget that there are sort of you know
there are more than a dozen of these
gatherings being investigated by sue
gray and ultimately if the prime
minister seemed to have had disregard
for the spirit of the rules as much as
the rules themselves the public won't
necessarily be very happy about that and
that anger will be
will almost inevitably be passed on to
their mps who are already feeling pretty
febrile and uh you know the prime
minister's in a very dangerous position
yes um
well but tuesdays uh the guardian does
have the latest picture of bryce johnson
out with his pre-dawn run with his dog
dylan does he not but the eye
talks about uh the mood amongst tory mps
um so my question was as the eye reports
that the conservatives have fallen 13
points behind
how is boris johnson doing with all of
this i mean this is what not what all
pre prime ministers want is he is he
taking phone calls from concerned tory
mps has he got cabinet tomorrow what
will they be saying to him harry what's
you know what what's what's the mood in
downing street
it's fairly funeral i think at the
moment basically government is slightly
paralyzed now until sue gray uh comes
back with her her report it won't be a
definitive you know sort of guilty
verdict or not but it could be extremely
uncomfortable reading if she makes it
clear that she thinks that the the rules
were breached or that you know advice
was ignored we'll have to wait and see
on that one but by all accounts the pm
speaking of sources is fitting between
somewhere between optimism of saying
we've got to fight this come on let's
crack on let's let's fight back let's
get keep the show on the road and
actually being fairly down in the dumps
about the whole thing and sort of waking
up to quite how much trouble he's in um
look
it's gonna be you know he's been
slightly hampered by the fact that
um
his
family members come down with covid
obviously the rules uh say you don't
have to why state but it's recommended
that you cut off all
unnecessary contacts so
visits that you'd normally expect to see
them haven't done the last few days
visits to vaccine centers and schools
and the usual prime ministerial sort of
post-covered fodder that we've seen got
so used to recently hasn't been able to
do there's
i think we might see him tomorrow but
his next sort of public appointment in
the diary is another another round of
six with um with kia stammer in the
commons chamber and cummings as hannah
handed him uh you know the leader of the
opposition some fairly incendiary attack
lines here now look it might not
necessarily be the the scandal uh the
original scandal that gets you john
perfume didn't resign because he chased
christian killer around a
swimming pool
he resigned because he lied knowingly
and deliberately lied to the house of
commons that is i think the benchmark
for a lot of sensible middle-of-the-road
tory mps who are not rocking the ship
now only six of them are calling for the
prime minister to go at the moment 1.5
of the of the conservative elected
conservative party so there's a lot a
long way to go before that sort of
inevitable tide of criticism can't
become so or he faces a confidence vote
but if he's bound to have lied to the
house i think he's get his game over but
it's um if there's a gray area over he
said than she said then
you know this could run one for for many
weeks yep
ten stays ahead uh no doubt for all
there um both of you stay there lots
more to discuss
including is the number of migrants
crossing the channel is projected to
double what can be done to address the
issue
what is the plan back with that in just
a moment
[Music]
welcome back to watching the press
preview uh with me now peppa carrera and
harry cole from the mirror and the sun
respectively welcome back to both of you
um harry let's go to the daily telegraph
uh one of these uh elements that we were
presented with over the weekend apart
from the bbc was about migration uh lo
and behold here is pretty patel in the
commons uh suggesting that the figure
pulled out by the telegraph here uh that
migrants could double but of course this
is all about defense as well and what to
do about the journeys being made across
yes well the operation red meat as it's
being called in the sunday papers and
firmly denied their like all great
stories on monday morning um but there
is it's true they are trying to chuck
some chucks and some policies out the
door to try and move the news agenda on
a little bit now the problem with uh
grabbing a policy off the shelf and
announcing it before is ready is it
falls apart quite quickly we've been uh
sort of stress testing this one all day
that this idea that suddenly the navy
are going to be called in you know this
is what tory mps have been calling for
the mp for dover particularly saying you
know send for the navy to to to police
the channel to stop the small boats
the reality of the situation is i think
it's going to be a bit more like the
vaccine task force or testing where
there'll be some brilliant no doubt um
naval officers who will be seconded to
the home office to take control get a
bit of grip on the situation rather and
take you know overall control of assets
in the channel
rather than actually the idea we could
see the aircraft carrier you know
blocking off dover and destroyers
patrolling the controlling the shores
because actually border force have the
boats to do that
um that is their job that is their role
and the navy probably don't really want
any part of this because
actually you know it's a real hot potato
now being shoved around whitehall if
they can get a grip uh in terms of
uh sort of more joined up thinking
across government to stop this fine but
um i think it's been slightly overspun
in a in a febrile climate to distract
some woes yes harry i should have got
you to talk about your paper which is
the sonic boom plot to stop the dinghies
you know desperate downing street policy
chiefs have explored using sonic weapons
to repel small boats we've only got 30
seconds left quick thought from you if
you don't mind
well it's a fascinating story by harry
is this idea that um policy chiefs are
looking at using sonic weapons uh
long-range acoustic devices um which
they can then aim at small boats it
fires out a sort of a
sonic i don't know what the terminology
is but like a really intense sound which
can make people very ill and vomit the
idea being presumably that it would then
it would encourage them not to make the
journey because they're likely to be met
by this awful awful sound and this
feeling